no matter what game you play just about
every top team you face is gonna have
that
one standout player someone who is
capable of putting the team on their
back and getting the job done
in just about any situation edg they're
retreating to the wrong side of the map
at this point flandre about to turn mega
keep your eyes on him tm goes for the
1v1 heroes entrance it's trying to
protect the jungler as well don't be on
the back line in comes flandre but the
stopwatch has come on through flight
drawing with a huge gnar ultimate maybe
this is it but fbx still firing out
goes five minutes
what how does viper do it some of these
stars are flashy highlight machines
capable of pulling off plays
that most of us could only dream of
they've been given a lot of room now
while others pride themselves on
consistency letting their accolades
speak for them
up again
he's unrelenting at this moment and he's
absolutely unstoppable turbo on the hunt
for yet another hat trick already two
we're not even halfway through this game
going up against players with huge
reputations like this can be
nerve-wracking because there's always a
strong possibility that they'll produce
something
spectacular in flanked electronic
looking for the cleanest finish he's
been turned on
zai wu no health really but he's still
hitting shots he's already got three and
four and five and oh my god zai wu but
in the brief history of valor and
esports no single player has struck fear
into the hearts of their opposition
quite like jacob yay
whitaker the gasp-inducing aim-god of
team envy whose reputation for
collecting souls has earned him the
nickname
el diablo
34 health
dancing around the corner he gets three
and diablo baby you gotta fear him look
it for four this is why you fear this
man a phenom so frightening that if he's
on your team victory is almost
certainly guaranteed
lay back
relax enjoy the carry ladies and
gentlemen
but if you are unlucky enough to find
him on the other side of the server
you might as well start begging for
mercy
i will never i will never pick him
against the movie
don't stop now
oh my god yellow drone trying to work
his way out but it's immediately denied
however yeah can still find music oh my
goodness yay three kills now coming out
from the office that's one of the fun
things running mirror comps
tangible differences in how these teams
stylistic i didn't talk to you on
twitter so how did a harmless looking
guy like yay get nicknamed el diablo
where exactly did that title come from
and better yet how has he embraced this
whole demonic persona that the community
has made for him oh my god
diablo
i gotta reload
one more time
all right so before we get into yay's
story please do your boyfriend like the
video subscribe to the channel and turn
on notifications
because who else is going to tell you
about all these cracked kids out there
okay so what exactly is the backstory
behind envy's 23 year old anime fragging
machine well hailing from the great
state of indiana yay's journey to
becoming an fps god began at a very
young age when his father first
introduced him to medal of honor but it
was when he discovered call of duty that
the world of esports revealed itself to
him while most competitive cod players
used controllers yay like a true man of
culture preferred mouse and keyboard so
he entered cod's smaller pro scene on pc
which didn't exactly go as he expected
the only anti-cheat was like back and
like all the guys were like convinced
like absolutely like convinced that was
like cheating we were like playing a
game i was just having that i was having
a serious i was like spamming people
through walls
like i don't know it was like a really
good game for me and my own team
actually ended the game and they kicked
me out and they're just like
yeah cheating isn't cool dude i'm like
but yay's unexpected exile from call of
duty ended up being a blessing in
disguise because it was around that time
he started playing cs go after working
his way up through faceit and esea yay
eventually hit rank s
but once he got there he faced another
obstacle the there was a there was like
a situation before where i joined like
ranked ass and fdl and got kicked prior
mainly because uh i think at the time i
was at my mom's place and i was getting
like
i had the worst internet play available
but i still wanted to play like a whole
bunch so i got kicked out eventually yay
fought his way back to rank s and even
placed first in some events during his
initial month back earning him praise
from other big name players in the scene
offers started rolling in for yay but it
was in july of 2017 that he decided to
join his friend android on complexity
however after nine months of mixed
results ogna vets shazam and stanislaw
were brought in as reinforcements with
the arrival of his new teammates yay
helped complexity qualify for the 2018
face it major in london he had finally
made it onto cs go's biggest stage and
he was ready to prove that he belonged
there
as well
[Music]
great shot from yay double with the awp
crush he's in the middle of nowhere you
can tell and he's gonna go down to yay
his job to turn this corner immediate
dink yeah he's ready for the next one as
well he gets that too
and now how do you get this bomb planted
scout from above tagging you and there's
the peak yay quad kill in the round one
of the first
real owners in esports as a whole this
bomb plant isn't even gonna go down and
yay's done it who better to close it out
now unfortunately for yay complexity's
cinderella run would come to an end
against mibr in the quarterfinals and
while a top eight finish was certainly
something to be proud of especially for
an n a team
yay's major debut
hadn't come without a cost but i would
say like during my time with the
complexity or like towards like the end
i kind of like ran into like a situation
in which like i was dealing with like a
lot of like mental health
kind of related stuff and i would say
like like especially like after the
london major instead of like i i would
say like taking like a break you know
and like taking like a week or two off
or like two or three weeks kind of like
the solution and this wasn't by stan's
law but kind of kind of like my like
upper management was like hey we're on
the hot streak let's keep going you know
like i started getting like really like
burnt out of the game gradually yay's
performance for complexity started to
decline and by the end of the year he
found himself sitting on the bench an
unusual position that left him uncertain
about his future for like over two weeks
i was like kind of like depressed in bed
like i could not leave my bed like
whatsoever it was it was a rough time
but after that i really started working
on like dealing with like hey what do i
want to do like do i still want to
continue to kind of strike this is what
you know makes me happy like i tried i
tried to figure out like um
you know like who am i like it was kind
of like it was like a i don't know if
it's like a
i'm making it seem out to be like some
like meditation like journey but like i
was i was seriously like trying to
figure out like hey like what do i want
to be like what makes me happy as like a
person after deliberating over his
professional future for over five months
yay did eventually decide that he wanted
to continue his career in cs
though his return didn't exactly go as
he'd hoped after joining with bad news
bears in may of 2019 he spent the next
year hopping around various north
american teams but in spite of the fact
that yay and his teammates on his
eventual roster orgles were
outperforming some actual salaried
rosters
no offers came their way because well
frankly nacs was sort of heading for the
[ __ ] orgs were dropping from the
scene like flies esl introduced
exclusivity rules to pro league and more
importantly there was kind of this new
kid in town stealing all the attention
like
all our offers that we had and when we
were on this pulled out
basically valerie did 39. after playing
the same exact game for seven years
yay was starting to get kind of bored of
counter-strike like many others yay saw
the promise invalid not only did it
offer him the chance to establish
himself in a fresh new game that was
generating a lot of excitement but more
importantly it presented him with an
actual career path and thanks to the
similarities it shared with cs it didn't
take long for him to pick it up
yay was hooked he grinded the game for
months dumpstering just about everyone
in solo queue and in september of 2020
his hard work paid off when he was
unveiled as part of andbox's new valorem
team but over the past year yay has
developed quite the reputation for
himself he isn't just a ranked demon
he's the ranked demon somebody who
everybody fears
[Music]
in fact teams found playing against ea
so demoralizing that they began
referring to him by his now famous
moniker
el diablo like some of the pro players
on there because like that was their
like nickname for me because like uh at
least in scrims i was just dropping like
30s 40s like non-stop right and i found
out originally it started from wardell
actually wardell like gave me that like
nickname and then like sabrosa like
popularized it wait this theme is
actually oh my god
oh
[ __ ] boys oh my god he's el diablo it's
like when you see him alive even though
he's one hp and it's 1v4 you're like
maybe he can win this like like you're
like look at that
he can win this
i don't know it's just a meme to me you
know like just like everyone talks about
like ranked demons and then like some
people are like this is like the actual
you know the re the demon above all the
ends you know kind of thing that was
what they were saying i was like
i just thought it was like super funny
and honestly it just started it also
even started become like a little bit
like a brand thing so i'm just like you
know what i'll just i'll take it i'll
take and run with it you know
unfortunately for yay even though he
consistently fragged out in pro play and
box just wasn't able to find their
footing in the north american scene
perhaps it was the constant
quarter-final losses or maybe even the
38-round overtime loss against tsm but
after falling short for almost a year
with various iterations of the roster
yay decided that he deserved more i have
like these goals and like these
expectations and things like i want to
do and like if we're not like if we're
not moving forward if we're just like
people aren't like willing to give it
their all like it's just like it's kind
of like a situation which like i don't
wanna i don't wanna be a part of that
environment you know like i feel like
you have such limited time in esports
you know ultimately and everyone has
like a finite amount of time and like
you don't want to waste it around
sitting stagnant or like whatever you
call it you know because you never know
what's gonna happen ultimately a bidding
war broke out almost immediately with
every top team vying for el diablo
services
but in the end he signed with envy where
he would be reunited with his former cs
teammate fns and to say that yay's
arrival made an instant impact
would be one hell of an understatement
in his first event with envy he helped
them qualify for masters berlin and once
he was unleashed on the world stage
he did not
keep pushing disappoint
and yay
brilliant connection
there is a read there they have been
able to topple the strategies of
nitro and hundred thieves he goes down
as yay enters b was able to get one
under f well yay what a shot
yeah he's in a clutch spot here he does
have
one bullet left with the object that's
that blades from online if he's able to
get that all right he's good for one
it's gonna be on to steal
he has to creep his way forward a red
bull clutch from yay it's really hard
playing against somebody like that and
nitro knows because he his entire cs
career he had to play against monsters
and today we we fought a monster so good
against exceptional jay
good
excuse me yay okay forces him off if the
spam comes in he goes right back out oh
wait yay what can you do the right click
he's just doing that what am i watching
what am i watching envy did eventually
come up short against gambit in the
grand finals but the fact that they made
it that far having only had yay in their
lineup for a few months was an
impressive feat only a year and a half
ago yay's future in esports was highly
uncertain he watched the north american
cs team crumble before taking a gamble
on valorant
and thankfully
it paid off not only does he now find
himself the star player on one of the
best teams in the world but also the
owner of a pretty badass brand although
that hasn't distracted him from keeping
his eyes on the prize obviously you know
getting to the grand finals is like
amazing but i'm just more happy that
like we at least like so far like we're
continually like getting better and i
think it's like as long as you're
constantly like working to get better
like the results are like a byproduct of
that you know so as long as you continue
to improve and
in those aspects i think i think you
know that's great whether envy can build
upon their impressive master's
performance at champions remains to be
seen but with a player like el diablo in
their midst
doesn't seem smart to bet against them
okay i mean like i guess i'll take it
you know
it's the best ability in the game it's
just not even close it's just like it's
ruins overwatch like it's just it's
literally if your team gets antied it's
over it's
over you're done if your hog gets antied
dead ryan gets antied dead like there's
nothing
today today i'm gonna go to the workshop
and program jungkook
[Music]
that's the most cursed thing i have ever
heard anyone say bro all right we're
going back to the shoot now that's on
that note that's uh
that's nightmare fuel